well it's it's been a little while but
the force is still strong with this one
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so we got a bit of Star Wars news
and hopefully I can talk about Star Wars
without there being a friggin flame war
in the comments seriously guys this is
just a announcement for what's going on
with one of the TV shows can we keep it
civil for once
yeah I'm starting to dread talking about
this topic don't don't make me stop
because I like Star Wars anyways so
there have been announcements of a new
Star Wars TV series for a little while
you know a live-action not just you know
cuz we're getting the revival of the
Clone Wars and and you know stuff like
that but I mean Jon Favreau
do you know director John fact Jon
Favreau director of the original I
actually first two wired man but ii want
something good but the first two Iron
Man films he is you know executive
producing this new show and we have a
title for it and it's called the
Mandalorian before you get yourself too
excited official word on this seems to
indicate that it is neither boba nor
Jango Fett this is said to be set
between the return of the Jedi and the
force awakens and the very brief sort of
little log line that was given seems to
indicate some other character who would
be able to hold the title of Mandalorian
the exact words of the synopsis is as
follows after the stories of Django and
Boba Fett another warrior emerges in the
Star Wars universe the Mandalorian is
set after the father the Empire before
the emergence of the first or
we follow the travails of a lone
gunfighter in the outer reaches of the
galaxy from the authority of the New
Republic okay so what does this say it
says first of all that they don't know
their audience worth of dang if they
think if they think Star Wars fans are
going to give a crap about any
Mandalorian who isn't Boba Fett that
said they might know that and I would
not be shocked if it either turns out
that this character is going to later be
revealed to be Boba Fett
down the line and there and there
stupidly trying to hold that off as a
twist or failing that that Boba Fett is
gonna show up at at some point he just
is like it's good it's called the
Mandalorian you not having Boba Fett in
some way involved you know if it's if
it's something stupid like somebody has
taken up his armor or you know his name
or something but he's still dead I don't
think anyone's gonna care
I really don't and and I think they
might know that but we'll see so the the
whole thing with jon favreau being
involved i don't know what to make of
that
because the the man's got you know his
his best chops are in film he's worked
in TV before you know he's directed a
number of pilots but the shows that he
had capacity he had a role similar to
what he's supposed to have on this would
there were two there was Revolution
which was got decent reviews and only
lasted two seasons and then there was
the shannara chronicles' which got
middling reviews and also only lasted
two seasons so he doesn't have the best
track record on TV so far that said I
mean you know the man does does no film
fairly well and you know maybe he hasn't
had the right material but III would
have I would have preferred like
somebody with a stronger television
background than Jon Favreau
you know to be heading this up and maybe
they'll partner him with somebody who is
more experienced but at the same time
you know the people with the kind of
steady creative hand that you will
probably want for this probably don't
want to be answering to somebody else
and would want that level of control so
who knows how this is gonna pan out so
I'm a little bit iffy on his involvement
not because I think he's bad for it but
just because I'm going by his TV track
record which is not the best there have
been rumors of a live-action Star Wars
TV series forever like supposedly this
was what George Lucas was going to do
instead of doing episode 7 8 9 and like
but his problem was that the episodes to
have them beefed up to Star Wars
you know standards were gonna be so
expensive that it was cost prohibitive
except we now live in the age of Game of
Thrones where we have in we have
one-hour episodes of television that
have you know they have the budget of a
small film so you know the the TV
landscape has changed and and we now
might be ready for something like that I
don't I they need to be able to have it
visually on the level of the film's they
do because the films are there for
comparison so that's that's what's gonna
be really tough is gonna be controlling
the cost because unlike something like
say Star Trek where you have the benefit
of you know the interior sets of your
ship that's a fixed set you build it
once you just use the heck out of it and
then as necessary you can write scripts
that don't require a ton of additional
alien stuff a bunch of special effects
for space fight or you know an alien
world or whatever you can work around
that
but with the world like Star Wars it's
harder to say with the the sort of the
way the description is it sounds very
while Western so I have to wonder if
it's gotta go for more of a I mean for a
lack of a better better way to put this
sort of a you know Wild West
Tatooine cantina kind of vibe and have
it more or less than a fixed location at
the very least for the first season and
then maybe taking off in later seasons
assuming that it does well enough to
justify the cost that's me just
completely spitballing I'm going out
very little but yeah the the title
implies Boba Fett the synopsis says not
he's gotta be in here somewhere
that's that's my way of thinking on this
but what do you guys think Star Wars a
live-action TV show oh and also for my
money I don't I didn't see where this
has been confirmed if it hasn't it will
be this is gonna end up being exclusive
to Disney's upcoming streaming service I
guarantee you that because this is the
kind of thing that you put out to make
the service more enticing no it's it's
what is what Titans is supposed to be
for the DC streaming some nobody really
likes the look of that thing yeah so for
my money it's totally gonna be that but
that will thought I put my thoughts on
this one live-action Star Wars show
though Mandalorian whatever that ends up
meaning what do you think it means what
are your thoughts about this whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff to do buttons links including
one that takes you to my patreon plus a
whole others but a lot of others besides
check them out if you feel like it but
if you don't don't sweat it because just
remember you're the council I only run
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]